produits très différents à 10 francs
mais 24 avril au 3 mai humiliations de
toutes les religions ce soir à notre
dame en faveur des sept moines français
enlevés il ya un mois en algérie tuerie
en australie un tireur fou a battu 32
touristes et s'y réfugier dans une
maison avec trois otages formule 1 1re
victoire de jacques villeneuve dans le
prix d'europe sur le circuit nürburgring
madame monsieur bonsoir il ya maintenant
un mois que sept moines trappistes
français ont disparu de leur monastère
en algérie enlevés par un commando des
intégristes du gia qui réclame la
libération d'environ 200 de leurs
militants prisonniers notamment en
france ce soir en la cathédrale notre
dame de paris le cardinal lustiger avait
organisé une cérémonie oecuménique en
faveur de leur libération en présence
des familles thierry curtet matthew g
sept sièges brûle désormais en la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
cette cierge pour sept moines pour le
cardinal lustiger qui les a lus mais ils
brûleront autant de temps qu'il le
faudra pour rappeler les prières des
sept moines privée de liberté
le cardinal a tenu à rappeler quelle est
la mission des sept moines trappistes de
l'abbaye notre dame de l'atlas
ils ne sont pas partis pour conquérir
mais par amour
ils se sont voués au silence car c'est
leur règle par amour de dieu et de leurs
frères
la cérémonie s'est voulue au cul munich
et représentants des musulmans de france
et des juifs de france étaient associés
dans l'assistance un espace était
réservée aux familles des sept moines
devant eux
le représentant de la mosquée de paris a
tenu à s'exprimer que dieu at la
libération des sept reprises trappistes
kidnappé qu'il ouvre pour eux les voies
de la délivrance il facilite pour eux
les causes de la misère cornes et de la
liberté amen dans l'assistance de
nombreux fidèles probablement plus de
1000 personnes visiblement très ému très
touché par l'appel des trois religions
il ya une chose qui est bien regrettable
c'est que ça soit pas tous les jours
comme ça où tous les peuples se tiennent
la main dans la main et ça c'est très
plus belle chose que j'ai vue quelle que
soit la religion quelle que soit la
couleur de peau tout le monde était la
main dans la main pour la même cause
ça c'est très bon cela fait un mois que
les sept moines ont été enlevés
personne n'a voulu évoquer les
revendications le seul message ce soir
ici prier espoir
c'est avant-hier seulement un mois après
leur enlèvement que les intégristes du
gia ont fait savoir que c'était l'un de
leur commando qui avait enlevé ses sept
moines français en algérie jusqu'à
présent toutes les recherches entamées
par l'armée algérienne sont restées sans
résultat et on ne sait pas si une
négociation s'est engagée entre le
gouvernement algérien et les ravisseurs
ou encore entre le gouvernement français
et c'est même ravisseurs olivier
dernière la patrouille algérienne a fait
et refait mille fois cette route qui
mène à médéa
mais c'est comme chercher une aiguille
dans une botte de foin
les sept moines trappistes reste
introuvable pas la moindre trace pas le
moindre indice tend ce maquis où les
caches sont innombrables
c'est un groupe soudé de moines français
enlevé il y à un mois de leur monastère
qui est donc entre les mains du gia et
qui fait aujourd'hui l'objet d'un
chantage d'un marchandage qui place la
france dans l'embarras le gia menace
d'égorger les sept moines si jacques
chirac refuse la négociation les changes
des religieux contre certains militants
islamistes incarcérés en france et en
algérie
le communiqué du gia diffusé par ce
journal arabe il ya 48 heures maintenant
stipule que les sept moines sont vivants
et en bonne santé
mais rien n'est moins sûr depuis un mois
le monastère de l'atlas est placée sous
haute surveillance
le père robert est resté là épargnée par
les ravisseurs pour rien au monde il ne
quitterait cet endroit connu pour être
l'un des fiefs du gia
chinhoyi ciotti d'une double cheddar
était celle avec nos amis algériens et
celle o'shea plus récentes avec les
pères qui m'ont hébergé otages chantage
le gouvernement algérien et le
gouvernement français maintiennent un
black out total devant ce marchandage
la traque se poursuit au grand jour si
négociations où il y as avec le gia
elle se déroule dans le but
grand secret 32 morts innocents une
vingtaine de blessés graves
c'est le bilan provisoire de la tragédie
qui s'est déroulée ce matin près de port
arthur en tasmanie nil au sud de
l'australie
un jeune homme d'une trentaine d'années
armé d'un fusil s'est mis à tirer au
hasard dans la foule les visiteurs d'un
site touristique de la région ce soit le
tueur s'est réfugié dans une maison en
compagnie de trois otages mary pierce à
midi ces images d'amateurs ont
enregistré les premiers impacts des
balles tirées par le forcené
le tireur fou exige actuellement un
hélicoptère pour quitter l'île alors que
des unités spéciales de la police
négocié sa reddition et la libération
des trois otages
le forcené qui a tiré à bout portant au
hasard tuant ou blessant ou traumatisant
ceux qu'ils croisaient serait un malade
mental avec un passé psychiatrique un
acte pour l'instant inexpliqué aux
conséquences dramatiques pour l'instant
il est encore absolument impossible de
dresser un bilan du nombre des victimes
parmi les 18 blessés et évacués à
l'hôpital le plus proche quatre sont
dans un état désespéré
cette tuerie qui a eu lieu dans cette
île touristique et le plus grand drame
qui connut l'australie depuis 30 ans à
la suite d'un acte commis par un
déséquilibré retour en france ce
bousculade évanouissement c'était une
véritable pagaille ce matin à bordeaux à
l'heure d'ouverture des guichets de
réservations pour la finale de la coupe
de l'uefa match retour le 15 mai à
bordeaux entre bordeaux et le bayern de
munich en fait rien n'avait été prévu
pour assurer la sécurité du public
françois privat bernard bonheur au petit
matin
la bousculade certains attendaient
depuis plus de douze heures devant les
guichets fermés ils sont de bon millier
fatigués d'avoir trop bu et peu dormi
une quarantaine d'évacuation dix blessés
légers pour tenter d'obtenir un billet
de la finale bordeaux bayern de munich à
moineaux léger coup de rester ici mais
j'ai cru mourir ici on se retrouve
écrasé contre un débit chez les chats
étaient là depuis hier soir 7h30 ils
auraient dû mettre des barrières depuis
7h30 hier soir on a été complètement
chamboulée
ça pousse ça pousse de partout il est
avec eux y aurait du monde et c'est
débile une organisation dépassée vers 9
heures les forces de l'ordre et quelque
part hier pour leur apparition mais
c'est déjà trop tard
la sécurité publique n'est plus garantie
la foule compacte incontrôlable affole
les dirigeants des girondins de bordeaux
à ce moment on craint le pire
le président a flu a tenu à faire une
ouverture au public et s'est battu pour
qui et c'est plié ses 10000 e place mais
je crois qu'il aurait fallu cinquante
mille et donc nous n'aurions pas
solutionner le problème de toute façon
dans l'affolement de nombreux
supporteurs renonce d'acquérir des
places vendues entre 150 et 1500 francs
seule la passion du foot permettra
peut-être à ces jeunes d'oublier la peur
bref on est toujours sans nouvelle ce
soir des deux membres de médecins sans
frontières enlevés en tchétchénie
c'était d'hier il s'agit d'une femme de
nationalité belge et de son interprète
un russe les ravisseurs réclament une
envie une rançon d'environ un million de
francs en allemagne il ya 48 heures
maintenant que l'héritier d'une des plus
grosses compagnies de tabac et de
cigarettes du pays a été libéré par ses
ravisseurs qu'ils avaient retenu pendant
un mois dans un endroit tenu secret sans
que la police n'intervienne
la famille a payé la rançon aujourd'hui
les policiers peuvent enfin commencer
véritablement le rock
jérôme qatar route quadrillée par
d'incessantes patrouille aéroports
surveiller une gigantesque chasse à
l'homme lancée par la police allemande
pour retrouver les ravisseurs de jan
philipp rytz ma héritiers de l'un des
plus importants fabricants européens de
cigarettes
il a été enlevé pendant 33 jours par des
inconnus avant d'être libérés dans la
nuit de vendredi à samedi dernier contre
le versement d'une rançon de plus de 100
millions de francs les enquêteurs ne
disposent que de peu d'éléments car
comme l'avouent ce responsable de la
police criminelle
jan philipp rytz mas était enfermé dans
une cave
munis de volée d'acier des chevilles
enchaîné il n'a pas pu dire grand chose
alors les policiers ont décidé de
diffuser l'enregistrement d'une
conversation téléphonique entre les
ravisseurs et la famille de l'otage
une diffusion originale chacun en
allemagne peut écouter cette voie en
appelant simplement un numéro de
téléphone
bien entendu elle a été électroniquement
déformée mais les enquêteurs espèrent
malgré tout obtenir une piste de cette
façon car il faut dire que pour
l'instant les méthodes classiques n'ont
pas donné beaucoup de résultats
aujourd'hui l'ancien otage est parti à
l'étranger pour se reposer et tenter
d'oublier
quant à la police il lui faudra sans
doute beaucoup de temps et de chance
pour identifier arrêter des ravisseurs
qui semble-t-il ans commis peu d'erreurs
et retrouver la rançon que été
international il ya maintenant quarante
huit heures que le cessez-le-feu est
effectif au nord d'israël et au sud du
liban
les trois à quatre cent mille libanais
qui avaient quitté leur vie des villages
il y a quinze jours sont donc de retour
pour constater les dégâts et aussi
enterrer leurs morts dorothée olliéric
france brice
elle pleure pour le sang versé par des
innocents elle crie contre l'arrogance
et la machine de guerre d'israël ces
femmes demandent aussi à dieu que ne
meurent plus jamais sous les obus un
enfant du sud liban aujourd'hui à
nabatiyé c'est toute une ville qui
enterre ce martyr
c'était le 18 avril neuf membres d'une
même famille tombait sous les
bombardements
il y avait une femme son nourisson de
six jours trois de ses fils et trois de
ses filles ainsi que le fiancé de
greendale les assassins peuvent
aujourd'hui admirer leurs oeuvres dit
une femme elle parle des canons
israéliens qui sont là à quelques
centaines de mètres à vol d'oiseau en
haut des collines pointé sur la ville
est ce qu'elles font très rares au liban
est-ce que faisons une rolls et cost low
cost le low cost au liban d'autres
martyrs ceux du hezbollah
il est interdit aux hommes fait sont
tombés sous le feu israël
pendant deux semaines ces combattants
ont nargué la plus puissante armée du
proche orient
aujourd'hui ces soldats de dieu ne prom
plus uniquement la révolution islamique
il appelle aussi la population à
résister contre l'occupant israélien
et c'est sans doute pour cela qu'il
gagne chaque jour un peu plus le coeur
des libanais les musulmans du monde
entier fêtent aujourd'hui l'aïd el kébir
la fête du sacrifice du mouton en rappel
du sacrifice qu'ils étaient prêts à
effectuer abraham qui était prêt à
sacrifier son fils à dieu cérémonie à la
mecque où les pèlerins étaient venus en
masse environ 2 millions entre hier et
aujourd'hui à l'occasion de cette fête
les musulmans de france tu donc le
mouton une pratique longtemps resté
clandestine dans des conditions
d'hygiène parfois à déplorable c'est
pourquoi des lieux d'abattage officiels
ont été mises en place reportage à huy
dans la bande dans le val d'oise
valérie gaget christian durand un
dimanche à la campagne pour 400 familles
musulmanes venues aujourd'hui à lui
célébré l'aïd
ce site d'abattage le plus petit des
sept que compte le val d'oise a été mise
en place l'an dernier sous le contrôle
des services vétérinaires ici rien n'est
laissé au hasard les musulmans doivent
venir choisir leurs moutons à la ferme
dans la semaine qui précède l'ied
numéroter les bêtes ne sorte de l'enclos
qu'au dernier moment ce sont des
sacrificateurs expérimentés qui les
égorge pour nous essayons de nous
rapprocher le plus de l'esprit des lois
c'est à dire que nous imposons des
conditions très strictes en termes de
protection animale les animaux sont
choisis et réserver sur le site
aucun animal ne peut sortir vivant du
site et aucun animal qui n'a pas été
acheté sur le site ne peut être abattu
sur le style
en france plus de cent mille moutons
seraient vendues chaque année pour l'aïd
prix de l'animal entre 600 et 1500
francs pour les éleveurs français ces
jeux pas d accès vidal mais comme vu la
pénurie enfin vu les problèmes que
l'élevage ovin rencontre c'est un
débouché très substantielle les
musulmans semblent préférer ces sites
ouverts où ils peuvent venir en famille
aux abattoirs traditionnels car pour eux
l'aïd est aussi un symbole de
convivialité
quand je parle à nyon s'est pas
personnellement pour moi elle en a pas
mais pour ce qu'ils ont fait à part je
partage les airs fois moi je partage
avec les gens
après le sacrifice la famille at il
rejoint sa cité d'aubervilliers assène
le faire des couples moutons sa femme va
passer une bonne partie de l'après-midi
à cuisiner tous les morceaux
ce soir le festin sera joyeux en arabe
aïd el kébir signifie la grande fête on
cite souvent l'allemagne en exemple aux
français comme pays d'une parfaite
organisation et bien les manifestations
qui ont eu lieu aujourd'hui prouvent le
contraire au moins dans certains
domaines comme celui du commerce trouver
un commerce ouvert en allemagne en effet
très compliqué le samedi et le dimanche
et pas très simple en semaine avantages
de notre correspondant jérôme qatar pour
un touriste débarque en allemagne
comprendre les heures d'ouverture des
magasins est un vrai casse tête car si
en semaine les portes ferment à 18h il y
a beaucoup mais alors beaucoup
d'exceptions
mais samedi cours par exemple où les
achats ne sont plus possibles après 14
heures et les samedis long où l'on peut
faire ses courses jusqu'à 16 heures sans
parler des différences entre l'été et
l'hiver bref c'est compliqué et c'est
surtout peu pratique
les allemands eux-mêmes supporte de
moins en moins ces ouvertures de
magasins à éclipses et souhaiterait
avoir plus de temps pour leurs achats
moi je travaille dans la journée anormal
toujours très
pour faire je pense que les gens
seraient lions est resté longtemps à moi
chacun devrait pouvoir ouvrir ou
longtemps s'il le veut le gouvernement
semble décidé à donner raison aux
consommateurs il a élaboré un projet de
loi visant à allonger les heures
d'ouverture des magasins de deux heures
par jour en moyenne seulement le
syndicat des salariés du commerce et
contre les knicks à prolonger les heures
d'ouverture ne changera rien au pouvoir
d'achat des gens et donc les magasins ne
ferait pas plus de bénéfices ils
seraient obligés d'envoyer le même
nombre de personnes
mais pendant plus longtemps les
dirigeants des grands magasins estime au
contraire que s'il pouvait ouvrir plus
longtemps cela permettrait de créer des
emplois
car les consommateurs moins stressés par
les horaires achèteraient plus on induit
des achats d'impulsion donc une
augmentation du chiffre d'affaires c'est
à dire forcément oui l'augmentation des
emplois
on ne peut affirmer que les emplois
n'augmenteront pas que si on y
l'augmentation du chiffre d'affaires
love avec l'autre en fait au-delà des
arguments économiques
il s'agit d'un vieux débat ici les
organisations syndicales mais aussi les
partis traditionnels et l'église ont
toujours voulu protéger les conditions
de vie de chaque salarié
ouvrir les magasins puis longuement
entraînera sans doute une profonde
modification de la société allemande de
phrases politiques en ce dimanche soir
sur europe 1 monsieur bart au ministre
des affaires sociales a estimé qu'un
refus d'accès aux soins pour les
immigrés en situation irrégulière tel
qu'il est préconisé dans le récent
rapport parlementaire sur l'immigration
clandestine n'était pas acceptable
monsieur gaymard sur rtl ministre de la
santé estimait que la sécurité sociale
française n'a pas vocation à être la
sécurité sociale du monde entier même
s'il n'est pas question de demander
l'origine de quelqu'un quand on doit lui
soit dans le cadre de la foire de paris
s'est ouvert un autre
notre foire traditionnelle elle a aussi
le concours lépine qui existe depuis
1902 il n'y a pas que des inventions
farfelues au concours lépine loin de là
douze mille brevets ont été déposés en
95 et c'est au concours lépine que
furent présentés il faut s'en souvenir
le premier réfrigérateur le premier fait
rare passé le premier aspirateur et le
premier pressurer luc baziz un jean
michel millet bienvenue au royaume des
magiciens ici on imagine tout même
l'inimaginable cette chose pas plus
encombrant plus qu'une table à repasser
se transforme en un clin d'oeil en
chaise puisant tabouret avec sa table et
cet acrobate n'est en fait qu'un parent
et ceux qui refusent de descendre de son
échelle pour la déplacer alors un peu
d'idées et surtout un petit coup de main
et l'ensemble avance
ça roule comme sur des roulettes ne pas
casser une biscotte en labourant tient
aussi de la magie se tartine heures
composé d'une motte de beurre et d'une
lame est supposé vous tirer d'affaires
mais qu'importe
mais parfois ça marche
peut-être un peu de biscottes avec le
beurre pour éviter ça voici une
invention dissimulés dans le bush une
soupape véritable chambre de
décompression
cette année la deuxième qui reste l'un
des cours de 6 à son mal à l'extérieur
rien de solide et et laroche en salaire
est très facilement vagit de
l'électronique cette fois pour démarrer
la voiture tourner la clé de contact ne
suffit plus il faut en plus avoir bouclé
sa ceinture et la plus besoin
d'équilibrisme plus ou moins périlleux
pour placer son vélo sur le toit de son
auto la force d'un doigt suffit
les voici la serpillière magique qui
absorbe qui absorbent plus qu'on imagine
en un seul passage en une seule
opération vous allez récupérer avec
super boîtier des quantités dont
phénoménal les magiciens du lépine ne
recule décidément devant rien ils lui
font cracher le feu jusque pour nous
prouver qu'elle résiste au lavage à 90
degrés c'est sans doute le plus grand
rassemblement de motards en france ils
étaient 6000 aujourd'hui à saint lô dans
la manche où il se réunit chaque année
depuis 18 ans maintenant ambiance plutôt
bon enfant jérôme laurent gabriel calmes
hier
elles sont chaque année de plus en plus
nombreuses et milliers de motos qui ont
fait de ce halo en presque deux décades
l'un des rendez vous phares de tous les
motards résistants de se retrouver à
nouveau notre club de saint lô
participent à des rassemblements de gens
là régulièrement donc on se doit un jour
ou deux
d'inviter tous nos amis qui nous invite
et pour cette 18e édition la mécanique
commence déjà à être bien roulé et
huilée ils viennent de toute l'europe
savourer l'ombre des premiers pommiers
en fleurs fraternité oblige la moto ce
n'est pas seulement une histoire de cuir
et de gros cubes mais aussi de
retrouvailles
je suis déjà venu il ya des dix ans à
peu près mais bien que j'avais plus de
moto2 j'attendais de leur faire un petit
peu pour revenir parce que cheikh
ordures sont bonnes c'est sympa de
bahmani parfois même on vient avec
toutes les familles
m'enfin bon petit la petite car à 14
mois
tu es mon beau frère
on roule à 50 km à regarder mais après
quand on a démarré sans viande
et ne croyez surtout pas qu'on ne vend
si si des bruits et à la vitesse
certains rêvent vous emmènent parfois
bien plus loin au restaurant terre après
la saison d'hiver les stations de
montagne se reconvertissent pour l'été
aujourd'hui première sortie du vélo club
de l'oisans dans les alpes vallée astruc
olivier robert et vous me faites pas
vous tfc leur première sortie cyclo cinq
mois qu'ils attendaient ça
le vélo-club de loison reparti sur la
route des cols andré angèle et kylie
n'ont pas froid aux yeux
première mise en jambes la montée de
l'alpe d'huez
alors il n'y a plus de neige en pouvoir
faire des kilomètres on va leur mettre
sur la courge
on va leur mettre une panacée jeunes à
nous la montagne plus de vacanciers sur
les routes les stations de ski ont fermé
première monte un peu pénible mais au
bout la récompense améliorer leur
palmarès c'est évidemment le but de leur
saison mais aujourd'hui l'entraînement
sera tranquille après l'effort la balade
champêtre l'air frais les rencontres
aller et avec vous allez on va rouler on
va faire perdre la graisse à partir
d'aujourd'hui un gel qu'il y ait en
dressant fileront 400 kilomètres par
semaine
c'est ça être mordus de la [ __ ] un
plaisir qu'ils partageront toujours
tiens voilà la nouvelle vague qui arrive
à propos de champêtre une initiative des
agriculteurs de la drôme l'opération de
ferme en ferme découverte de la campagne
par les citadins un succès inattendu
plusieurs milliers de personnes avaient
fait le déplacement benoît gadret
championnat les petites chèvres sont là
on peut les voir les poules et les
cochons normalement ils sont dans des
petites écuries bien caché journée
portes ouvertes à la ferme des murs la
famille clément aime recevoir et cela se
voit sonia a passé la robe de sa
grand-mère pour présenter ses 85 chèvre
sa mère elle nourrit en public les
chevrettes gestes quotidiens qui ravit
les petits citadins
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont différents elle
marche inquiète les connais bien parce
que la ferme ne désemplit pas
l'opération organisée depuis quatre ans
connaît un succès croissant savoir
combien les chefs halfon de l'est
comment on a fait pour arriver à ce
petit fromage qui trouve dans la grande
surface veulent connaître le du début
jusqu'à la fin et je trouve que cet
intérêt je croyais qu'il y avait été
oubliée revient les gens s'intéressent à
nous on n'est pas vous m'expliquer le le
mot et cul-terreux fois le savoir-faire
entre tradition et modernité
titulaire d'un bts sonia rejoint
l'exploitation familiale
après de multiples stages en europe vous
voir ce sont des gens qui ont fait des
écoles d'agriculture ou d'autres
formations vie qui parle bien qu'ils
savent s'expriment ils savent recevoir
et bien que ça fait un lien entre ville
et campagne et pourquoi pas faire naître
des vocations
autre rendez-vous à la campagne
rendez-vous à fourcès c'est un
magnifique petit village vous allez voir
dans le gers classé monument historique
chaque année depuis 20 ans on organise
là bas un marché aux fleurs dont la
recette sert à financer la restauration
des bâtiments du village jacques cardoze
frédéric board
c'est l'histoire d'une bastide en pays
d'armagnac ronde et fleuri une fois l'an
et de cette floraison dépend son
existence car ce village du gers n'a
d'autre ressource que le tourisme alors
lorsque les beaux jours apparaissent
vient le temps du marché aux fleurs à
l'initiative d'une association art et
biscou la renaissance en gascon
l'association ray disc ou là et
promouvoir qu'en forte et restaurer une
qualité de vie tantôt niveau du site que
des hommes c'est à dire que tous les
bénéfices réalisés par le manifestation
faire vite intégralement à
l'embellissement du village embellir
l'image d'un héritage exceptionnel car
force s est uni seuls villages de france
construit tout temps au xiiie siècle
tous les habitants devaient faire face
au château érigé au centre sur
l'actuelle place cette année 60
horticulteurs du grand sud-ouest ont
répondu à l'invitation de l'association
et de ses bénévoles 110 bénévoles sur
327 à bitang cantal comment c'est
quelque chose d'important
et si nous n'avions pas les associations
demain belle force et sur l'engagement
les il n'est pas question de laisser
mourir fourcès ici on rivalisent
d'innovations
chaque année les habitants choisissent
teinte m pour son 21e anniversaire la
vigne et le vin
histoire d'être en harmonie avec sa
région avec ça les 20000 visiteurs du
week-end diront sans doute que le
bonheur est dans le gers
c'est une initiative plutôt originale
d'une agence de voyages romaine dont
nous allons parler maintenant aborde ces
autos cas vous pouvez à la fois
découvrir les ruines antiques mais pas
seulement grâce à des images virtuelles
vous allez pouvoir ensuite remonter le
temps le rêve de tous les hommes
finalement alain de chalon les ruines de
roms ont leur charme et leur romantisme
propre mais le touriste lambda un
archéologue a bien souvent du mal à
imaginer ce que fut la capitale
impériale de l'antiquité à partir de ces
pierres c'est pourquoi un tour opérateur
a eu l'idée de proposer à ses clients un
voyage dans le temps en même temps que
dans l'espace
lorsque le petit car arrive sur un site
ce que l'on voit par la fenêtre on le
découvre aussi sur l'écran ce qui
n'aurait qu'un intérêt très relatif
si l'écran ne se mettaient pas alors à
reconstituer le passé en images de
synthèse
et le touriste peut ainsi littéralement
se promener dans le forum de trajan
gigantesque centre commercial de la rome
antique
comme ça on a la possibilité d'avoir une
culture liée au monument qui voit
mettant bien des rêver un peu aidé pas
seulement imaginer comme elle était là
voilà comment étaient voir comment
c'était c'est donc l'objectif de ce tour
virtuel et de fait on peut ainsi entrer
dans le colisée mais hélas le cirque est
toujours alors à piennes lines a eu
aussi l'idée de racheter les droits de
certains péplum qui permettront aux
touristes non seulement de voir mes
devoirs vive et aussi de participer un
peu aux fameuses georgie romain
avec modération bien entendu tel père
tel fils le québécois jacques vignes 25
ans à peine le fils de gilles villeneuve
tué en course il ya une quinzaine
d'années vient de gagner son premier
grand prix de formule 1 en allemagne cet
après midi arrivée chez les grands
débuts de saison il confirme donc son
immense talent dont frédéric bonnet le
moment tant attendu tant rêvé est enfin
arrivée sur le podium jacques villeneuve
se frotte les yeux est ce une larme pas
sûr tant le jeune canadien était
étonnant de maîtrise de calme et de
talent pour son quatrième grand prix
seulement il a réalisé des prouesses
résistant pendant trente tours à la
pression terrible de schumacher
schumacher devant son public au
nürbürgring au volant d'une ferrari
retrouver duel de titans au sommet roue
dans roue entre un néophyte est un
double champion du monde
mais le plus jeune ne va pas craquer le
président de ferrari qui avait fait le
déplacement a beau en courage et
schumacher l'allemand ne passera pas et
c'est bien jacques villeneuve
débarrasser de damon hill seulement
quatrième de jean alesi qui s'est
éliminé tout seul au premier tour
jacques villeneuve donc qui donne son
premier grand prix et écrit une des plus
belles pages du sport automobile
même s'il reste sérieux et modeste
vous savez ça n'est qu'une course je
suis content mais demain ce sera déjà
loin car il faudra penser au prochain
grand prix c'est vrai c'est bien d'avoir
une victoire à jacques villeneuve où le
parcours d'un surdoué pour qui la vie
n'a pas toujours été ça à 25 ans sa
maturité est stupéfiante à la mesure de
la pression qu'il subit certes il est
talentueux mais c'est surtout le fils
d'un ancien champion
jacques avait 11 ans lorsque gilles son
père s'est tuée en 1982 jack qui a
grandi dans ce drame qui s'ennuie aussi
des livres et il est maintenant un
authentique champion en lutte pour le
titre mondial dès ses débuts en formule
1 le canada a bien de la chance
tennis finales du tournoi de monte-carlo
cet après midi il a fallu cinq sets au
roi de la terre battue l'autrichien
master pour l'emporter face à l'espagnol
alberto costa l'autrichien a remporté le
dernier set 6 2 il se présente donc
comme le grand favori du prochain
tournoi de roland garros la mort à l'âge
de 85 ans du réalisateur de cinéma
gilles grangier parmi ses succès
plusieurs films notamment avec jean
gabin comme le gentleman d'epsom et
surtout le célèbre cave se rebiffe servi
par un grand michel audiard au billet
vert
gilles grangier c'était toute une époque
le cinéma se met encore en noir et blanc
les hommes les vrais arboré gabardine
chapeau mou les tractions allait
toujours de l'avant
les gars pas réglo prenait encore des
corrections et l'on disait des choses
qui ne s'oublient pas dans la langue de
michel audiard
le cinéma de gilles grangier il se
conjuguer avec fernandel bourvil
brasseur arletty ventura et bien sûr
jean gabin dans voir avec cette semaine
est vrai je reconnaîtrais à bohain et
des petites bakang anglais à comps
d'accord l'airé rencontré monsieur est
un gabarit exceptionnel
si la coloriste mesurer ici revient à
une maîtresse allons mon travail à moi
je ne peux parler que du mien c'est pas
tellement un travail de direction
d'acteurs si vous voulez c'est un
travail de dosage
parce qu'un acteur généreux et les bons
acteurs sont généreux et toujours
tendance à donner le maximum de ce qui
peut donner dans une séquence et ça il
faut que nous n'osions parce que ça nous
fasse ça fera un film en dents-de-scie
et il faut qu'un film évolue sous une
certaine ligne et je crois que dans les
années le seul à pouvoir faire ça parce
que il validait de son montage
gilles grangier régis circuit
accessoiristes et des presque tout fait
au cinéma
en quarante films il avait su s'attacher
des suffrages du public son dernier tour
de manivelle datait de 1978 banlieue sud
est un feuilleton en couleurs et pour la
télévision mais si gentiment je
m'adresse ailleurs mieux d'africable
sortie la semaine prochaine d'un film
américain intitulé la cage aux oiseaux
une copie conforme du succès français la
cage aux folles où s'était illustré
d'abord dans la pièce de théâtre foirail
0 puis ensuite 0 ugo tognazzi cette fois
ci ce film sort avec notamment comme
vedette robin williams les américains
ont toujours préféré acheter les droits
et refaire les films français à succès
plutôt que de diffuser leur version
sous-titrée nicole cornu l'ombre
on travaille sur une plage de floride la
cage aux folles est devenu burke et non
d'un cabaret de south beach et nathanël
n est albert le danseurs travestis sous
la direction de mike nichols et robin
williams et armand l'énergique directeur
de cabaret qui fait rire tout le plateau
du tournage mais aussi celui de notre
entretien mais en mandatant une personne
avec un grand coeur j'espère les mains
son fils il m
albert et j'aime le club et l'ama dans
ses leçons correa veut faire oui un
excellent corrigera l'a13 inventif et
l'on vous tourner certaines scènes
totalement fidèle à la cage aux folles
fait super du doigt les gens beaucoup
aimé la cage où je crois que le film est
une sorte d'hommage à la pièce et aux
films fonctionnent certaines personnes
m'ont demandé mais pourquoi tu accepté
ce rôle c'était tellement super en
france est une magnifique fait quinze
ans que le sujet correctement l'amérique
de joe lally cela lui dira si comme lui
même comme étant bon préservatif le
dîner est servi
c'est ce dont j'ai toujours rêvé depuis
toujours une belle famille qui s'aiment
l'hypocrisie des notables est toujours
d'actualité chez les vertus familiales
disons une différence et pas de drogue
ni de site a servi par des acteurs
remarquables constamment créatif bercail
ne fait pas oublier la cage aux folles
mais on s'y amuse beaucoup
votre engagement que ce duo infernal ne
va pas s'arrêter là et prépare déjà un
package numéro 2
au revoir bientôt un communiqué de la
présidence de france télévisions france
doit demander au tribunal de commerce de
paris de désigner un expert pour évaluer
le coût des émissions produites par la
société de jean-luc delarue réservoir
prod uction cette décision a dû être
prise à la suite de demandes réitérées
de la chaîne à la société de jean-luc
delarue de fournir des comptes détaillés
de ces émissions s'interrogeant sur
l'adéquation entre le prix payé par
france 2 pour ses émissions et les
prestations fournies par réservoir prod
uction france 2 avait fait procéder en
1995 à une évaluation par un expert
désigné par elle-même
les résultats de cette expertise avait
conduit à faire des observations au
producteur animateur puis à saisir la
justice
statuant en référé pour la désignation
d'un expert indépendant
par ailleurs france 2 a mis fin au
contrat passé avec jean luc delarue pour
l'élaboration de programmes nouveau
celui ci ne donnant pas les résultats
attendus
france 2 a cessé les paiements sur ce
contre contestant cette décision jean
luc delarue a assigné france 2 devant le
tribunal de grande instance de paris
voilà sur ce on se quitte le dernier
journal aux alentours de minuit philippe
lefait demain matin télématin 6h30 avec
william leymergie 13 heures benoît
duquesne et puis je vous retrouverai
avec beaucoup de plaisir demain soir à
20 heures je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur france 2 bonsoir
albin